listen we know that you've sat down with  Barack Obama we know you sat down with  Elon Musk we know you sat down with Kobe  with Bill Gates all of the Illuminati  and you some people think you're  Illuminati do you know that uh that's  who thinks that yeah what I thought that  was like the Entertainer's tart part of  the Illuminati you're in the game My  friend I guess a little bit I've only  been in that room once I went to the Met  gal at once whoa so I've been in that  room just to just bring that out to the  top of the podcast but uh I wouldn't say  that those people you mentioned are in  that same category now so you're saying  they're not on your level no no that's a  difference I guess I'm separating the  Illuminati from Kobe Bryant I guess yeah  I don't think Kobe's was part of it